what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
today Gravity Falls we're getting part
three John how are you I'm excited for
the end of times how are you me too
can't wait for the world to end and I'm
also excited for Gravity Falls ladies
and gentlemen we are almost at the end
so all we ask is that right now you go
ahead and leave a like and full length
rational watch Longs or you sync up with
your own copy for Gravity Falls
available for our super sexy Rejects at
our patreon page become a super sexy
region today to check out all we have to
offer exclusively with reaction
highlights and watch along as included
and to the team of prepper thank you for
helping us edit down these highlights
for this entire Journey let's get to it
foreign
hugging strangers to practice for this
moment we missed you you old conjure
I've missed you Knuckleheads too good to
have you back
staring at camera disembodied wax head
wants num nums we're trying to ration
our food remember
it's happening again
disgusting every
where it's okay mad Glenda
invasive Maneuvers
skip it down
oh
wow just one more episode after this
it's crazy Ryan
welcome to What's Left of normal around
here
home base
we have several injuries
it's got an arrow in his hat
do not be afraid weirdmageddon has
taught me there are some battles I
cannot win I am now humble Mick Skirmish
no so I was hammering signs out back
when the sky started vomiting nightmares
I listened to a lot of AM radio so I
knew what this meant the end of the
world Coast to Coast George Noory plans
to stay in here and eat brown meat until
we run out then I vote we eat the Gnomes
hey I'm short not deaf
stress will make you chewy
[Laughter]
serve that jerk right my brothers had
some stupid plans going up against an
all-powerful space demon was its worst
one yet trust me we have everything we
need right here sure you're just gonna
stay here
Jimenez reporting live
viewers are advised to look away wow
fantastic camera work that's a great
zoom lens my family
is there no one who will save the people
of this town I'm Chandra Jimenez and I'm
being turned into stone by a flying
eyeball the town's folk thrown
if we band together if we combine all of
our strength our smarts whatever Toby
has Jerry yes rashes no have you ever
gotten who's in charge here besides
we're only safe inside it's not like we
could take the Mystery Shack to Bill
[Music]
wait a minute I meant to say I think I
figured out a way to fight Bill and
rescue four but we're all gonna have to
work together now
just the five of them
just disgusting
should be a group discussion
are they gonna make armor out of the
wood of the shack
is made from living human skin
wow Texas Chainsaw couch
uh sharp as ever fordsie as you may have
noticed I've recently had a
multi-dimensional makeover I control
space matter and now that that
cool as it turns out my weirdness can't
escape the magical confines of this town
there's something keeping me in
incredible Gravity Falls natural law of
weirdness magnetism
if you just tell me that equation
finally your dimension will be free
anything will be possible
whoa
we make up the world a better world a
party that never ends with a
with a whole restriction no more laws
I'm on Bill Cipher's side everyone
that won't be used for evil blueprints
are incredible McGucket this is your
most amazing invention yet it doesn't
have any guns I watch a lot of anime and
You're Gonna Want Some Guns
we have much to discuss discuss nothing
this scribbles are a bunch of cockamammy
Balderdash
is
[Laughter]
very good
yeah
wow how are you getting how'd you get
all that
yeah know your target inside and out
hey hey nice
shoot him Adam
please create some type of anime device
otaku McGucket
yeah take back the force well maybe if
you're hitting the mystery check you
wouldn't have been captured guys trust
me tomorrow's gonna be great I Believe
in Us I keep accidentally flexing
through my sweater
[Music]
good cow monsters are delightful come
we know you're gonna try to save him to
just go grunkleston everybody ready
Dipper now anime robot
anime robot
Gundam gravity
forgive me boy you're half of flammable
merchandise is the only thing keeping me
going
oh hey is the swimming pool guy ready to
talk now I won't let you into my mind
how do you think
500 volts
what I just fixed that door
oh
Gravity Falls
dude that is cool
I just wanted you monster dudes to hand
over Ford or we'll have to like fight
and junk I have butchered Millions I
liked you better before you talk bring
down this
one
oh cool we got the music
yes drift compatible
awesome
gobble Walker oh yeah
yes Wendy nicely done
[Music]
oh she's so badass
[Music]
[Applause]
dang
mushroom cloud
like one job to do here Bravo Dipper and
Mabel well would you look at that those
kids really care about you and you care
about them I'll wake up
what are you oh oh no perhaps torturing
those kids will make you talk no no oh
my let's get this over with
[Music]
that's not torture that's Annihilation
yeah
we got him distracted now's our chance
Rescue Team
[Music]
the hook
[Music]
you guys are doing it the memory Ray
oh so many things coming back
[Music]
oh man oh man
Godzilla
[Music]
Ah that's actually a lot harder than it
looks and you got the all right Landing
right right in the holder
worse up close close of course it does
those are people
she's propelling off those people
and let's get out of here
and freeze them I know
get in get a young lives forced to dance
for eternity
dude dances in his cage for all eternity
I'm so tired
how do we undo this oh mayor Tyler he's
the load bear in human pull him out and
the whole thing goes down really
whoa wow that was it
to pull one guy oh it tastes like
nightmares ah I think I'm dark and
tortured for reals now this experience
will forever scar Tad strain
you'll be okay Ted strange
Wendy guys
Mom Dad
[Applause]
s ah you did it I knew I could count on
you too I haven't seen you since we
parted ways I've tried forgetting maybe
I should try forgiven oh
hey good to see you too bro now let's
get out of here huh listen Uncle Ford
that's very knowledge of it
[Music]
the world's most confused
confused Scotch no a prophecy although
it would be a pretty fun game of
hopscotch how'd you draw that so fast
okay
oh here now I finally understand that
it's Destiny Dipper the pine tree Mabel
the shoe shoe star question mark first
one's unsolvable
laughs
you've been rocking that dumb hoodie
since the seventh grade wow Destiny
hoodie the kind of telepathy signs
[Music]
I like you now Gideon
hey Achilles oh no
[Music]
this is a mystical human energy circuit
whose eyes the symbols needn't all be
literal Dipper it just has to be someone
cool in the face of danger yeah
holding hands tickles need to be someone
scholarly
yes three
now hold hands everyone free pizza
do it sweetie do the one thing no one in
our family has ever done
the hillbilly
acknowledge the existence of poor people
the rest of you get out it's too
dangerous
you just need one more person Stan
come on what are you doing you're gonna
ruin everybody hold hands this long and
I am very uncomfortable whoa hey Ryan
Reynolds hates you want me to shake your
hand say thank you fine thank you
between me and him I'm not always the
bad twin between him and me grammar oh
grammar Stanley no
everything's on the line
[Music]
I think it already happened right isn't
that what you're all thinking hey Gideon
why aren't you dancing Chop Chop huh
oh
that all comes to an end
one week from today
I've really been enjoying this Last Arc
here this final stretch because
it is feeling like an ultimate
culmination of everything from Gravity
Falls
one massive hodgepodge even the fillers
are getting acknowledgment here things
that make you go I guess that episode
was important because that guy's back
now
you know I'm not really important but it
ties it all together by having them come
back in at the final moments of this
series but this was a this is a rousing
episode it was an exciting one that
really is the first time you know you're
really rooting for them in a perilous
situation to take on the big Baddie and
to see how it's coming together with the
Mystery Shack the base home location of
this family animated sitcom series base
home location of that
become coming to life as this protective
shield and them all working together to
create some type of Transformer out of
it engaging in a really cool battle and
it was actually really cool action
scenes and there was something that did
feel cathartic about this moment
considering the bleakness of this
weirdmageddon situation and it has
reached this point with Bill Cipher
where he's always very entertaining to
watch but you're like I'm now at that
Pinnacle Point of
man I don't like this guy I really I
really want him to go down because he
seems impossible to feed this whole
situation does seem like an
insurmountable obstacle
and whenever we check in with him like
yo now you're an evil son of a [ __ ] I
really want you to go down now whereas
before it was always like it's always
full moon bills here and now I'm like
nah man you gotta go you gotta go we
gotta get the ax but then we gotta wrap
up some family resolutions and the next
episode lots of wrap up
we also got to do a whole wrap up in
character arcs of every one of the Town
folk of Gravity Falls we got to do every
single one of them otherwise I'm gonna
feel very dissatisfied and feel like
there was too many doors left open so so
we gotta wrap up Dipper and Mabel do
they make it to the 13th birthday what's
going on with Stanford brothers and then
of course Zeus and his grandma does he
ever meet his dad well we gotta check in
with everybody everybody's really
important it was really convenient what
happened with that chair though that was
too easy of a solution that's the one
thing about this episode that I thought
was a little bit of a nitpick was all
you have to do is pull the one guy off
and then bam it all falls apart like
come on should have been a little more
creative than that but what do you got
to do you only got one episode left John
your thoughts dad just ruined everything
for me that that load-bearing human I
couldn't uh you couldn't engage with any
of the rest of the episode after that
point uh I'm sorry to hear that John
it's okay it's okay you know if there's
ever a time to Fumble the ball it's
right at the end because who's gonna
remember after the whole journey that
preceded it fair enough
um nah for reals though this was great
this was great this was one of those
episodes where at the end I was like oh
my shoulders have been like raised in
tension this entire time and you know
Gravity Falls is a show that is very
enjoyable for various reasons but it's
not necessarily at the outset the show I
would have pegged for being like intense
that way and I like that they are able
to do that in a way that again seems
very mean Mabel
Mabel
said Abel oh yeah one of your stupid
dumb John jokes
yep that was great I loved it it was a
10 out of 10 John jokes it's so good I
could have made it myself the fact that
they were Mabel to do that to
orchestrate that was very cool and very
rewarding and yeah seeing all these
little bits and pieces and mcguffins and
things like that factoring in
to the solution also you know needing
necessitating a makeup of sorts between
stand forward and Stan Lee uh through
that you know good little Nifty
storytelling Avenue even Gideon and uh
Pacifica get little moments to be part
of the team and to shine out and to help
yeah like it feels like we've been on
quite a journey this summer and it does
feel kind of you know it's like as much
as you want the show to go on you're
like yeah these if you count these two
seasons is almost as if they're like two
months or something like that it's like
yeah we've been on this harrowing summer
vacation adventure and now next week
it's going to be the last day of summer
and I'm not ready to say goodbye but at
the same time you know as long as they
can glide it to a graceful conclusion I
will be satisfied and regardless of how
Bittersweet it is to say goodbye you
know I will be you know full up in my
heart and Imagination because this has
been quite a lovely experience overall
it has been an experience indeed all
right ladies and gentlemen well only one
more to go thank you so much for
spending your precious time with us
today hey subscribe click that Bell to
get notified when our reaction for the
last episode is up on the channel thank
you to all who followed us on our
patreon page that support has been a
savior as of late and last but not least
to send this with a
Michael B Omni media you've been
covering so much but it pains me
whenever I go to your channel and I see
you haven't covered Gravity Falls then I
realized
this guy's actually a lot lazier than I
expected I know you're always shooting
and editing and thumbnailing but come on
man it's just 22 minutes of your time
don't be lazy yeah just watch it and
then upload it squeeze it in anywhere
editing reaction videos takes no work in
no time I don't get why you're so lazy
it only takes as much time as it takes
to watch the show Michael you always hop
on camera and you're trying to just show
how exhausted you are and like okay yeah
congratulations all you did was sit
nothing drink some more wine well
Michael I think it's about time yeah
gravity falls into
your schedule I mean you could squeeze
it in with rings of Power House Energy
power just ended so House of dragon
and and uh and or squeezing she hopes
done now yeah you got to replace those
big hitters
gravity falls down even bigger hitter
like this
so Michael keep up the good work
good lazy work that you do yeah you are
one of the laziest people I've ever met
I hate you you just work a full-time job
and you come home and you sit you hit
record and then act like you're so tired
all the time
from doing this nothing nothingness
nothing you're the cancer of YouTube
you're nothing anyway keep being nothing
and we'll talk with each other soon Mr
nothing
thank you